ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد الى نقاش الملف
الثاني علي شمخاني الى خارج الساحه
السياسيه الايرانيه بعد عقود من الحضور
النشط وذلك بعد اعلان وسائل اعلام ايرانيه
استقلته من منصب امين المجلس الاعلى للامن
القومي الايراني والذي شغله خلال العشر
سنوات الماضيه شمخان الذي كان له ثقل
سياسي كبير على عده اصعده في ايران كان له
دور في ملفها النووي وفي تقدم مسار
المفاوضات رغم انه لم يشارك بشكل مباشر في
المفاوضات النوويه حيث كان حلقه الوصل بين
المرشد الايراني وفريق المفوضين النوويين
الذي يتولى منصب الامين العام للمجلس
الاعلى القومي عام 2013 اقترن توليه بهذا
المنصب بنقل صلاحيات المفاوضات النوويه
الى وزارات الخارجيه ورغم دوره في
المفاوضات التي انتهت بالاتفاق النووي عام
2015 كان شمخاني تحت ضغط خصوم الاتفاق
النووي ومع اعلان اقالته وابعاده عن
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي من المتوقع ان
ينعكس ذلك كما يقول مراقبون على مسار
المفاوضات النوويه خاصه مع عدم وضوح النهج
والدور الذي سيقوم به علي اكبر احمدين
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من طهران عبر
سكايب مصدق بوره الكاتب والاستاذ في
العلوم السياسيه ومن باريس ساندرين مهاوج
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكم ضيوفي
الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من طهران معك
سيد مصدق سيد مصدق مصلح للاسم كان نطق غير
دقيق
في الواقع قبل الحديث عن احمد او علي اكبر
احمديان
اسمح لي ان نتحدث عن منصب هذا الرجل لانه
حضرتك تعلم بانه شمخان سياسي حتى من تراس
مجلس الامن القومي في السابق سواء جليلي
او كذلك للرجال كلهم سياسيون ولكن احمد
ديان يختلف عنهم بما انه التجربه فيما قبل
هي تجربه عسكريه بالاساس وضابط تابعه
للقوات او تابعه للقوات البحريه تابعه
للحارس الثوري تغيير هذا الشكل وهذا
الحضور كيف يمكن ان ينعكس على المفاوضات
شكرا تحياتي لكم
انا اعتقد يعني اولا
الميرال شنبانيا ولم يقدم استقاله يعني
انتهت مهمته يعني مثل هذه المناسبه
الرفيعه لا يمكن ان تدوم لاصحابها لاكثر
من عشره سنوات وبالتالي هذا الشيء طبيعي
يعني
ذهب وجاء محل شخص اخر هو ايضا كان شخص
عسكري يعني وكان قائد القوه البحريه
الايرانيه وكان وزير الحرس الدوري
وتناصب عديده وبالتالي يعني يسمى الاساسيه
في شخصيه شبانيه كانت سياسيه امنيه
بالدرجه الاولى اكثر مما كانت عندهم
سياسيه اما فيما يتعلق بالسيد
مصدق شمخان لم تتم اقالته لانه قيل هناك
صحف
هناك لانه ايرانيه قالت بانه استعملوا
استعملوا عباره سانقلها لحضرتك قالوا اقيل
بغمزه وباشاره وكانه دفع الى الاقاله او
الى الاستقاله هكذا تتحدث يتحدث الاعلام
الايراني
بصراحه يعني انا انا لدي معرفه شخصيه
اعرف ما جرى يعني هو اساسا يعني انتهت
مهمته وكان منذ السابق يعني هم يفكرون
يعني نصب او تعيين شخص اخر مكانه وهو ايضا
يعني قبل يومه ويومين من الاستقاله وكتب
ابيات شعريه في تغريده لهيحي بها بانه له
يغادر هذا
المنصب يعني ايضا هو عين من قبل القائد
يعني الحكم من قبل المرشد الاعلى يعينهم
مستشار خاص له وبالتالي يعني هو سوف يلعب
دور يعني في المستقبل وايضا
يرى سيده مصدق حضرتك ترى بانه لا فرق بين
احمداني في التعامل مع ملف المفاوضات يعني
هذا ما اردت ان تشير له لا لا هناك فرق
كبيره ايضا يعني اولا شنقاني هو محسوب على
التيار الصحي بصراحه يعني
من قبل السيد روحاني هذا يوسف اصلاحي
السابق يعني
وانا ما هو ايضا شغل عامين ايضا من من هذا
المنصب في عهد رئيس الحالي هو
يختلف عن السيد احمد صحيح هو من من قرر
الحرس الثوري ولكن هو يعمل شخص قديمي
ويعمل في مؤسسه احاديه هناك مؤسسه ابحاثيه
الحرس الدوري في ناس يعني غير عسكريين
يعني فيها شخصيات
شديد حتى ننتقل لباريس انا اود ان افهم من
حضرتك سيد مصدق تقول بانه كيف سيؤثر
باختصار شديد انت تكرمت
لا ما هو سوف يؤثر يعني هو يختلف عن السيد
شوباني اولا هو شخص
اكاديمي ابحاثه وكل المقترحات التي تقدم
او كانت تقدم الى المجلس الاعلى الامن
القومي تحتاج الى الى من يدير هذه الملفات
ويجعل منها يعني برامج عمل وقطط عمل
واضحه واليات واضحه توزيع المهام على
الوزارات ربما سيد شنقاني بحكم انه كان
عسكري ربما من هذه الناحيه يعني لم يكن
يستفيدوا كثيرا من الجانب الابحا ولكن
صحيح ساعود لك سعيد مصدق
مسايد اندريه فيما يخص المفاوضات النوويه
بالتحديد مع خروج شمخاني
ووصول احمدان مكانه
جلوس على هذا الكرسي المهم جدا لاداره ليس
فقط شؤون داخليه ولكن شؤون الخارجيه وعلى
راسها ربما ملف المفاوضات النوويه هل
تعتقد بانه نحن في طريق ايجابي للوصول الى
امكانيه عوده احياء هذه المفاوضات او
احياء اتفاق بالاحرى او ان الموضوع الى
تراجع
نعم مساء الخير اولا
لا بد من القول في البدايه بان كل اركان
النظام الايراني ايا كانت التوصيفات
اصلاحيين متشددين او وسط وما الى ذلك هناك
سياسه هناك استراتيجيه واحده معروف من
يضعها والجميع يلتزم بها بغض النظر عن كل
هذه التوصيفات لا يمكن الخروج على الخط
العام الذي يضعه المرشد لاعلى هذه هي
مركزيه القراءه في النظام الايراني الحالي
حتى وان كنا نتحدث عن محافظين واصلاحيين
عند مجموعه يدفع بها المرشد الايراني علي
خمينائي وم
جموعه يساندها الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي هناك
انشقاق يتحدث عنه البعض او خلينا نقول
خلافات عميقه في داخل الايراني حتى هذا لن
يؤثر تعتقد
حتى الان استطاعت ايران استطاع نظام
الايراني ان يتخطى كل هذه الاحتجاجات او
ما عرف بالتحركات الداخليه اخرها كان كما
هو معروف في الاحتجاجات التي حصلت قبل
اشهر قليله وتم القضاء عليها وخفتت كل هذه
الاصوات المعرضه وتمكن النظام من الاعاره
الامساك بزمام الامور الوضع الان هو هو ما
هو مصير الاتفاق النووي هناك طرفان
اساسيان في هذا الموضوع طبعا هناك ايران
من جهه وهناك ايضا الطرف الغربي بقياده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اليوم هل هي تريد فعلا
العوده الى الاتفاق وضمن اي شروط الرئيس
بايدن واداره الرئيس الامريكي حدد هذه
الشروط هي اربع شروط اساسيه لا يمكن
للنظام الايراني ان يقبل بها اي ان يكن
الطرف المفاوض لذلك الاتفاق او المفاوضات
هي الان في طريق مسدود من بين هذه الشروط
كما هو معروف تخلي ايران عن موضوع
الصواريخ الباليستيه تخلي عن مد نفوذها في
المنطقه وعن دعم الاطراف او الجهات
المؤيده لها او الميليشيات او ايا تكن
توصفات ايضا هنا اذروا ايران او غير ذلك
الموضوع الاخر هو الالتزام بنسبه تقسيم
اليورانيوم نعرف ان ايران كانت رفعت نسبه
التخصيب من بعد ما تم تجميد الاتفاق هل
تريد فعلا العوده الى ما هو مطلوب او الى
الحد المطلوب من ذلك اعتقد الان بان ايران
ليس لديها مصلحه عمليه في العوده الى هذا
الاتفاق السبب الاول انه هذا الاتفاق
ينتهي مفعوله قريبا بعد حوالي يعني سنتين
او ثلاثه على الاكثر الشرط الامريكي مبين
الشروط كانت تمديد هذا الاتفاق الى سنوات
عشر سنوات اضافيه بعد العام 2016
الموضوع الثاني ايران كانت تريد المكسب
الاساسي لها من هذا الاتفاق هو طبعا رفع
العقوبات اعطائها بعض التحفيزات
الاقتصاديه والماليه على رغم الازمه
الماليه والعقوبات التي يعني تتعرض لها
ايران ربما ايران ترى الان انها لديها
فرصه من الافلات من هذه العقوبات من خلال
التوجه نحو اطراف اخرى مثل الصين وروسيه
واحد واثنين ربما تعتقد بان الاتفاق
الاخير
قد يقول
عن هذا الاتفاق صحيح ولكن قد يقول لك
بعضهم بان السوق الموازيه لمحاوله
الالتفاف على العقوبات لم تنفع كثيرا
ايران داخليا اقتصادها متعب منهك ونسب
التضخم فرقه الخمسين بالمئه في اخر
تحديثات هناك حتى حديث عن ما يفوق ال 60%
اقيل بانه هي تحديثات غير رسميه ولكن
الرسمي اكثر من 50% وهنا سؤال سيد مصدق هل
كما يقول ضيفي بان هناك فكر واحد هناك
منطق واحد فدخل الايراني لا يابه بتفاصيل
هذه المفاوضات او ان هناك سعي ايراني
داخلي لمحاوله ايجاد طريقه للوصول الى
محادثات حقيقيه لامكانيه ان يكون هناك
اتفاق نووي
طبعا هناك الكثير يخطؤون كما هو الحال
بالنسبه
انا اعتقد يعني اولا النظام نظام الحكم في
ايران ونظام لا يختلف عن بقيه الانظمه
يعني حتى في داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يعني هناك حزبان
يتقاسمان السلطه في داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هناك دوله عميقه على راسها بين
الحزبين وايضا في الكثير من الدول وحتى في
داخل ايران وهذا لا يعني ان السيد
الخامنئي او المرشد مرشد الدوله والوجه
قراراته بنفسه يعني اولا فيما يتعلق بهذا
المجلس هذا
المجلسه رئيس الوزراء ولكن عضويه هذا
المجلس ويمثل كل الاطياف وكل التيارات
السياسيه في ايران يعني وكل مناصب يعني
منصب رئيس
الدوله رئيس الجمهوريه وايضا وزير الدفاع
وزير
لا نختلف وهذا لا نخ
تلف بصيد مصدق ولكن منصب امين هذا المج
لس كذلك يمكن ان يحدد سياسته الخارج
المجلس هذا المجلس نعم هو يحدد مسائل
السياسه الخارجيه ولكن على راس هذا المجلس
رئيس الجمهوري سواء كان هذا الرئيس
اصلاحيا لو كان
اصوليا مبدئيا يعني لا فرق المهم يعني لان
هناك اكثر شخصيه اكبر من من المجلس وهي
رئيس الجمهوريه وهي راس يعني هذا المجلس
اساسا هو رئيس المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
ولكن
الشاب خاني وغيره كانوا يعني امين المجلس
الاعلى للامن القومي وبالتالي القرار هنا
يصدر يعني
هل هناك سعي هل هناك جديه ايرانيه في
محاوله احياء اما الاتفاق سابق 2015 الذي
يقول عنه البعض لم يعد قادر ان يفي
بالوعود او ان يكون حاضر مع كل المتغيرات
التي شهدتها الاطراف خلال سنوات الساب قه
هل هناك جديه حقيقيه في داخل الايراني
للوصول الى اتفاق النووي تعتقد
اعتقد يعني اولا هذا الاتفاق وفي حكم
الميت يعني هذا الاتفاق اساسا حتى لو
نظرنا الى هذا الاتفاق من حيث التسلسل
تراتيبيه الزمنيه يعني هناك الكثير من
البنود اكل عليها الدهر وشرب يعني انتهى
مفعول ذلك وبالتالي يعني هذا الاتفاق
ايراني اذا كانت يعني مصره وبقيت في هذا
الاتفاق علما ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي خرجت من هذا الاتفاق هي
التي مزقت هذا
الغربيين ايضا وعدوا ايران ولم ينفذوا
واديهم ولكن ايران اذا كانت متمسكه بهذا
الاتفاقيه تريد ان تقول العالم بانها يعني
تريد ايجاد حل سلمي لهذه الازمه النوويه
التي تؤديها اسرائيل الدرجه الاولى
وبالتالي هذا الاتفاق انا انا اعتقد يعني
في اعتقادي اليوم المتغيرات الاقليميه
والدوليه والتقرير الحاصل في القاره الجو
السياسيه والايكو
الاقتصاديه كلها سوف تكون مؤثره وبالتالي
اسمع تهديد من جانب اسرائيل في الواقع هذا
التهديد رساله الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لان اسرائيل تشعر بان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ما زالت يعني تريد ان
تتوصل الى وبالتالي هذا لا يروح للجانب
الاسرائيلي عندما نسمع تصعيد على عشيه ما
نسمعه من تصريحات امريكيه باحتمال العوده
الى هذه المحادثات اما ما نسمع بحظر
وتشديد والتهديدات انا في الواقع يعني
هبوط على ايران لكي تلين مواقفها دعم
ايران لن تتراجع كما قال الضيف عن شروطها
ولا تقبل هي في الواقع لن تتراجع وهذا
صحيح كما تقول حضرتك حسب قراءتك هي لن
تتراجع وهذا الموضوع استشعره كذلك رافال
جروسي الذي قال معلقا على الموضوع سيد
اندريه قال بانه هذه المفاوضات ستبقى
عالقه في طريقها المسدود قرا البعض تشاؤما
في هذا الت صريح ولو ان الاقرب
والاوضح
يعني صوره اوضح لا بما انه هو يتعامل مع
كل الاطراف بطريقه مستمره هل تعتقد بانه
فعلا المفاوضات في طريق مسدود تتفق معه
باختصار ان تكرمت
هذا هو الواقع نرى ان هناك جمودا في
المفاوضات بعد عده زيارات قام بها الاخيره
الى ايران زارت بعض المواقف منه كانها
تفتح باب الامل ولكن جاء الجواب اولا منهم
بعد ما لمس الموقف الايراني الذي عبر عنه
الناطق باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه عندما اكد
على حق ايران في مواردها النوويه بانها لا
ترتهن لاي طرف اخر حتى بالنسبه لاعاده
الكاميرات كاميرات المراقبه وزياره الوفود
وكاله الدوليه للطاقه النوويه منها ايضا
زياره موقع فورد والناطق باسم الخارجيه
الايرانيه قال حينها ان هذا الامر ليس له
علاقه بالاتفاق وانما تاتي هذه الزياره
ضمن اطار اتفاق حظر الاسلحه النوويه
العامه المعمول به بين كل دول العالم
الموضوع اليوم حتى حتى الطرف الاوروبي
فرنسا كانت ناشطه وكانت تقوم بدور وسيط في
مرحله معينه وكانت اير المستند الى هذا
الدوري الاوروبي لكي تلين الموقف الامريكي
اليوم الاوروبيون فرنسا تحديدا ليس لها اي
خطوه او اي خطوه تقوم بها حتى انا في
المده الاخيره اعلنت عن توقف ايضا وسطتها
لماذا ايران اليوم تشعر طبعا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لدى ايضا مواقف ولديها
نظرتها الى القمر ولا تريد ان تعطي اي
تنازلات ولكن ايران ايضا تشعر اليوم من
بين الشروط الاساسيه او هذا الطوق
الاقتصادي اللي كان مفروض عليها والعقوبات
تعتقد ايران براي بان اليوم فتحت صغره في
هذا الموضوع وهذا امر جيد طبعا من خلال
معلومات يجعلها
الخاص بهذا
الملفته ولكن في حلقه اخرى ساكتفي معكم
بهذا القدر شكرا جزيلا لكم على الحضور من
باريس سان هاوج الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
ومن طهران مصدق بور الكاتب والاستاذ في
العلوم السياسيه شكرا لكمما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات